I've never seen myself as particularly
talented where I excel is I'm willing to
die in the process of acquiring skill
working on on your body is the beginning
of everything you know your mind starts
to work better you're the better husband
a better father a better friend and life
is just better I didn't forget
but I didn't pay the IRS in my mind I
mean I wasn't like trying to avoid
paying taxes I was just like oh damn
they need a money need motivation watch
the top 10 with the leave nation what's
that believe nation it seven my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from being the son
of a school board administrator and
refrigerator repairman to becoming one
of the most bankable stars in Hollywood
he's Will Smith and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success vol 5 also
if you want to know what Will Smith and
other entrepreneurs have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 2:54 of confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a short 30 second to five
minute video for free to help build your
confidence check out the link in the
description below
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange you know as
an artist it was it was a fun to get out
on that on that limb and hoping it
doesn't break under your feet
okay let's kick it up with rule number
one maintain positivity
he was always challenged for that right
like all yourself you're different the
positivity was always challenged yeah I
always wanted you to justify being
positive right absolutely
yeah now that was a that was a difficult
time coming up cuz it's like I'm from
I'm from Philly right so during that
time in Philly it was Joe Frazier and
rocky so this fight was common yeah
Chuck D used to he called it pug City
he's like pug City is like he's like
Chuck was like you can't go to Philly
without getting in a fight so it's like
I grew up in that so for me too
it was always difficult for people you
know to say I was soft and I was you
know my music was cotton candy you know
that's all I always wanted to fight to
try to to to prove myself but the be
fighting yourself to maintain positivity
as the hardest fight you ever gonna have
right and it's like that struggle to
just stay my course to you know be the
person in the world that I wanted to be
no matter what people said and it was a
I started to call it offensive
positivity right like you know I wasn't
gonna be on defense with my positivity I
was gonna be on offense with it rule
number two seize your opportunities me
and Jeff had come out with smash hit
parents just don't understand we made a
bunch of money we want a Grammy album
with triple platinum
I have motorcycles and cars are called
the Gucci store in Atlanta and I was
like
I bring my friends and I'm smiling but
that's stupid we released our next album
and it was like a flop it was a tragedy
and went like double plastic I had spent
of most of my money like all of I spent
all my money and I didn't forget but I
didn't pay the IRS in my mind I mean I
wasn't like trying to avoid paying taxes
I was just like oh damn they need a
money the IRS took off with all that
stuff so I was like rope broke bro being
famous and broke is a sheet combination
because you're still famous and people
recognize you but they recognize you
while you sit next to them on the bus
and the stuff they ask you to sign on a
bus you know like oh can you sign my
baby
that's a sharpie I probably shouldn't
write on the baby with that are you too
big to sign my baby well no I mean you
know I signed it so I was like playing
around and my girlfriend was like dude
we're not doing this like you're not
just gonna be laying around this house
all day you gonna go do something I was
like what what I'm supposed to do go
where people is is doing it where people
doing it go to the Arsenio Hall Show
just go stand around at the Arsenio Hall
Show
yes that's stupid so I went to the
Arsenio Hall Show and I met a dude named
Benny Medina Benny Medina is the
real-life Fresh Prince of bel-air except
he actually went from watts to Beverly
Hills same basic concept way shorter
distance I meet Benny and he pitches me
the idea for this show and I'm like I'm
not an actor am i cool and he said hey
you know I want you to meet Quincy Jones
Quincy Jones's producer with me so by
myself like Quincy's and his actors and
artists and celebrities and politicians
like everybody's at $20 it's like The
Wiz without the costumes
so Benny walks me in and introduced me
to Quincy Lehane q what's up and say hey
man you know saw your music videos I
love I love what you're doing I love
what you're doing
tell me rap name again they call me the
Fresh Prince all right good that's what
we gonna call the show and he handed me
a screenplay for a failed Morris Day
pilot like I don't have the time so I
need you to do this I need you go ahead
take a few minutes take ten minutes
study the script and I'm gonna clear all
this stuff out the living room and we
don't have everybody sit down in the
living room we're gonna do an audition
he had movers that could reset his
furniture I was like this dude is real
so close I touch the brake come on come
on come on I was ain't you hold up man
hold up I'm not ready to do no audition
and he said oh all right well what you
need tell me what you need just set the
meeting for a week and I could do it he
said yeah yeah you know Brandon
Tartikoff
the head of NBC is out there I'll get
him a schedule for next week and then
you know what's gonna happen
something's gonna come up and then he's
wanting to reschedule oh yeah yeah so so
three weeks from now can we can do it
three weeks from now so yeah yeah yeah
three weeks now be good or you could
take ten minutes right now and you can
change your life forever I was like get
there yes give me ten minutes I said yes
and I let it rip and I got to the end
and everybody's clapping crazy
looks at brandon tartikoff the head of
NBC did you like it and Brenda said yeah
yeah I like because he says no did you
like it can you say yeah I like it he's
a good you're his lawyer Romney up
something right now rule number three
work on your body I used to be able to
eat whatever I want and then in six
weeks I could get in any shape I wanted
to get into but that's not the case
anymore we're we're around the twelve or
fourteen week mandatory training to do
anything but but I love it I enjoy I
enjoy the discipline of it for me
working on on your body is the beginning
of everything you know your mind starts
to work better you're the better husband
a better father a better friend and life
is just better when you you know care
for your body at the highest level rule
number four be obsessed I told the
famouser value kind of backed into
acting Fresh Prince of bel-air yeah and
the next thing you know you start making
these movies and I forget that bad boys
actually came before Independence Day
right yeah yeah Dennis day just was like
one of the biggest of all time like what
was that transition like for you yeah
you know actor and like the biggest
actor in the game no it was um that was
like the first real goal like that in
terms of setting goals I was like I want
to be the biggest movie star in the
world right and every up until that
point everything was like it was fun and
it was happening and we were creating in
Jeff's mom's basement and it was
successful but that was like when I
moved into acting that was the first
time I started applying skill to my my
talents right and you know I always look
I look at skill and talent separately
like Pete you're born with talent you
know it's like there's certain things
that you just do naturally you were
gifted with a talent and you have it but
skill is acquired through discipline and
you know I've never seen myself as
particularly talented where I excel is
I'm willing to die in the process of
acquiring skill like is you know when I
put my obsessive mind on a sign the
treads actly it's not working yes that
ridiculous is sickening working
sickening work ethic exactly it's like
you know so for me to be a movie star
was the first thing that I ever really
wanted like that and set my he was like
I was like I was like you know because I
went out when I looked I always felt
like there weren't a lot of people I saw
do things that I felt like I couldn't do
right when I when I look at people and I
see things I don't I don't feel like I
can't whether or not I will is something
different but I don't ever feel like I
can rule number five have a strong why
anytime I put something in the world
I am always connecting to an idea I'm
always asked why am I making this what
why I'm putting this out in the world
why so with with concussion dr. Bennet
Omalu was deeply connected to tell the
truth and he said that truth doesn't
have a side and that's what he kept
saying I thought that was such a
powerful that the idea that there you
know whose side are you on you're
Republican or Democrat I'm trying to
tell the truth truth the truth doesn't
have a side rule number six deal with
rejection rejection is everywhere you
know we all deal with the me worst of
all the worst of all you know I think
the idea of rejection is relative I mean
if you you take a you know a kid in a
small town and somebody posts something
negative about them and all that their
friends laugh you know that's the worst
rejection a human being can experience
it's not you know for that kid it's not
any less than for my kid to read
on a comment page you know it's it's
emotionally it's it's the same my kids
grew up in this world so they're much
more acclimated to the difficulties of
this world but it doesn't make it
emotionally more difficult or more
painful than for any other child who has
to deal with it
rule number seven be authentic you're
like the prince but now you're the king
of Instagram I know I was like how come
you've embraced social media in this way
like because for the longest you know
you have this mystique behind you
well in you know when I when I started
the the the only way to be a movie star
was through distance and mystery and
mystique right that was the the the way
is that you know yeah you could see me
on July 4 in the movie theater right so
that was the way keeping that distance
was how you maintained our star power
and in the last five years that shifted
much more to a friendship model like
people support artists that they feel
like they know thoroughly that they're
friends right so that the social media
the the daily interaction is much more
like a family friendship kind of
interaction that is an audience demand
for for you know their loyalty but is
there such thing as revealing too much
not in this world
too much data that's personal you know
like it's it's what can you handle you
know I think one of the major one of the
beautiful parts of social media that I
think is a beautiful evolutionary thing
is that social media demands
authenticity right so social media
pushes you more and more into having to
reveal what's true
because if you don't you know TMZ is
going to you know so it's you know it's
a beautiful thing I'm and I'm actually
enjoying the push right
nobody's happy who doesn't get to beat
himself right so the the the eyes and
ears of the world are starting to demand
more and more authenticity where you
gotta say was true for you and live or
die by what that is so I'm enjoying the
the social demand for authenticity I'm
coming into a space how have you
maintained you authenticity because I
mean you come from Philly it's going to
everything like your journeys being
crazy like how have you maintained that
um you know it's really interesting is
it's like the idea I I haven't
maintained my authenticity per se I've
maintained my character right I've
maintained my beliefs character in two
senses I've maintained my character of
Will Smith and I've maintained my
personal character of what I believe in
so but in terms of authenticity the
character Will Smith signs every
autograph and it's always happy and
wants to see the fans and is always in a
good mood and that's actually not often
authentic right
I actually I do want to slap somebody
you know every once in a while so in
terms of authenticity I have
successfully maintained positivity and
now I'm working more to maintain
authenticity I'm granting myself the
freedom to not give up when I don't give
a Yeah right and now I'm working into a
space of much more authenticity rule
number eight face your fears something
that probably a lot of people don't know
about me
I don't put the ocean the ocean is like
the ultimate woman
beautiful and she will nourish you but
she will tear you to shreds also the
ocean is my worst fear I don't know what
it is or where it came from but there's
something about not being able to
breathe I've tried snorkeling before and
I was hyperventilating my 50th birthday
is this year I just wasn't gonna go into
the back nine of my life without having
attacked my fear of the ocean so we're
about to scuba dive the Great Barrier
Reef you know I've never scuba divin
scoubidou scuba I've never been scuba
divers before so we're taking a boat
ride out and we go through a storm
probably 25 years old in my mind I would
be here one day so I'm ready I'm ready
this is stupid I'm not going is it okay
to punch sharks in the face back up with
your shark ass back up with your shark
ass
shucks ass back up yeah I got it the
question isn't can you handle the
situation the question is can you handle
your mind can you manage the thoughts
and the emotions that are trying to
poison your progress
forget managing the situation
manage your mind
[Music]
training your mind to sit calmly in the
eye of the storm rule number nine
inspire others to succeed you know
growing up my mother and father and
grandmother demanded no less of me than
to represent the family every time I
stepped out in a way that was helpful to
others the city gave him his start he's
worked hard in the city has worked hard
for him knowing that this man is no West
Philly opens eyes for that they opens
their lens when you're in Philadelphia
you see a lot of things in the youth in
the neighborhood that not always
positive and I think seeing that will
motivate you all in his own because
you're always gonna want something
better for yourself you don't have
enough role models out here you got too
many kids being led astray thinking the
wrong things is what's good they grow up
too fast you need people that's puttin
that out there like you don't have to do
this you don't have to do that it's so
much easier being yourself when you are
young kid and you're walking to school
you see images like this it makes you
aspire to wanna be that person right
what he's done in his life vibrate I'll
go overseas but touch you they touch
people yeah well but this right here
will affect people the main thing you
did you take the main detail yeah you
get wills ears right
this man was an icon is looking at GLA
so my kids everyday will see this image
and know that you can be whatever you
want to be this is a man who grew up and
filled up they went to over top high
school up the street was a part of this
world that he now is looking at us and
telling my children you can be whatever
you want to do it's just so powerful if
you're a kid here growing up now and you
see this every day it can give you a
real understanding that this guy is me
you know he lived here he grew up here
he had the same chances as me the same
possibilities as me the same everything
and he's being painted on a wall because
he's done something incredible with his
life and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is ask
awesome questions we're about to make
history we're doing an IG live to the
International Space Station
oh yeah and see now that's the paint
looks I'm doing it like that everybody
can do an interview to the International
Space Station and how shoes it in terms
of like the the simple basics right so
you on earth people have to poop you're
like it's important to poop on earth
right so when you're up there I see your
microphone floating I need to understand
what you do with that like how do you
manage that well are you sure you want
to talk about this this problem because
it is pretty challenging I like to say
you can have a good day in the bathroom
and you can have a really bad day in the
bathroom and you really you hope for the
good days the bad days can be
challenging on earth we talked about the
the you know the mile-high club there's
anyone you know attempted for research
purposes has anyone attempted you know
the process
procreating the human species in space
all right well similar to the last
question I'll just say are you sure we
want to talk about this I'm just you
know I'm a man of the people drew I'm a
man of the people and it's important to
me to ask the questions that the people
want to ask this to I'll just say as far
as I know I have no knowledge of those
tests being done but I can imagine that
that would present some unique
opportunities
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Will Smith on how to not chase
awards that I think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions had to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your business
and in your life
so with these questions write down the
answer in your notebook at home talk
about them with a friend or leave them
in the comments below here we go
question number one what current fear do
you need to face question number two who
can you inspire to succeed and question
number three what is your strong why
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much loved I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clip
first Grammy ever given to two rappers
and we boycotted right that year so they
the the Grammys weren't televising the
rat portion and we felt like you know we
had done enough that deserved to be in
the televised and they they really they
they everybody was still scared of rap
music at the time and thought it was a
fad and all that stuff so we received
our Grammy in in absentia I've never
used that word before I like that in
absentia you still happy that you
received that Grammy that award was like
bittersweet you know I've never really
been awards minded right so I like it
everybody you prefer to win and leave
that for right I have no I actually
don't know you know Jeff has me on a job
like he's like where is your Grammy I
was like dude I have no idea
I've not and I'm just not awards minded
I'm much more that box office locks
office yeah always yeah open it weekend
open a weekend yeah I'm much more it's
like total go see total like I like
winning at the box office
I like numbers I like sales and awards
are cool but it's like I never uh never
really never really got into the
excitement of winning and a war it's
like what you know with you know I've
been nominated for Academy Awards twice
and it's like it's it's nothing it's
like believing that feeling with the
film stuff that's never yes like I like
box office assassination altruistic
world domination
honey Empire right I'm
I understand why I'm here I think
because I am so open I wanted to think I
see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video